how sexy is that guy in a relationship
for real because he so doesn't give a
[ __ ] I mean zero percent sexy okay
I mean [ __ ] I have a question for Chris
how do I use a napkin
um where's my mouth
[ __ ] you become so sick with it well I
mean
oh wow you know just so that was the
best submission we ever gotten and
because of the chocolate on his face it
was so quick no what was good about his
it sounded like Chris cut his ass off
because it went too long right
like that wasn't the end of his video
that was the end of that oh really oh
dude
how to get too sick with it
Let's Play It Again look at his his
slovenly I have a question for Chris
Chris
um
how did you become so sick with it
thanks oh even better
first take those for our time first off
he started wiping his face when he had
[ __ ] all over it what do you mean that's
how you started oh that's how I started
me it's like step one or step one when
you when it looks like you have dookie
on your mouth yeah yeah wow dude so
that's number one yeah I mean dude
didn't give it that guy doesn't give a
[ __ ] honestly how sexy is that guy in a
relationship for real because he so
doesn't give a [ __ ] I mean zero percent
sexy okay if anyone was going in to kiss
that guy no when he had this [ __ ] on his
face but the attitude about it is that
he did the video and thought and
obviously saw he's not blind because
he's driving he wanted it like he
thought it was funny that's why I don't
know okay then never mind you know he
thought it was being funny all right
okay but he still has his question he's
pretty sick with it already he thinks I
mean you he's asking you I mean I
probably don't want to hang out with a
guy like that but he's pretty sick with
it okay because he's already he doesn't
give a [ __ ] that's what makes you say
these two things that he's already sick
with it eh and that you wouldn't want to
hang out with him well because I don't
want to hang out with a guy who thinks
it's good to have [ __ ] stuff all over
his face that's disgusting to me okay
period for any amount of time yes and
then uh he's already sick with it
because he doesn't give a [ __ ] what
people think obviously okay because now
he's on you know hundreds of millions of
people are going to see this yes
billions yes by the way subscribe to the
channel we need to bring break 596 this
is a conspiracy super cold sooner or
later even I who never believed
anything's a conspiracy will start to
think this is yeah neither do I do it
but I'm starting to be like okay man
maybe we're a little bit Alex Jones in
this [ __ ]
[Music]